it's coming your way hey hey it's video
of the day he
[Music]
hey he approached the bench with his
fists clenched a r the day comes from
the glittery butthole of America Las
Vegas where a 30-year-old man was being
sentenced for aggravated battery with
substantial bodily harm among others
that's something you'll never see these
days though criminals actually being
sentenced but when the felon's attorney
asked for probation and it is denied
this happened it makes more sense given
the circumstances and his ability to do
probation successfully that he be given
this opportunity I appreciate that but I
think it's time that he get a taste of
something else because I just can't with
that history in accordance with the laws
of state
of
[Music]
in San Francisco they'd call that an
argument for early
release ah the judge and the court
Marshals are saying some injuries but
they're doing okay the criminal's doing
fine too he's currently changing his
pronouns and growing his hair out to
prepare for serving time at a woman's
prison meanwhile in New York the tables
were turned when a defendant was
severely beaten by a judge who smashed
her way through several layers of
plexiglass
cat I have a theory that no one has
brought up the guy's name is
dibra so maybe he was transitioning but
he can't spell
Deborah
no just watching that video I feel like
that guy is not a feminist yeah like let
her talk he's definitely not excited for
the new Star Wars
movie that was crazy them jumping like
that though that was wild yeah it was
wild yeah you got like six feet off the
ground I know it's like they had a
hidden trampoline or
something yeah it was pretty wild I
don't know what do you think Tyrus that
guy has some uh what do you call that
UPS UPS or yeah but he's gonna have a
few Downs too
BR all all this is a horrible thing that
happened I mean the even three grown men
had a hard time getting him off but this
is the result of that whole no cash bail
no
consequences you're released and
criminals are expecting that now yes
their attorneys are expecting that yes
if you look at his rap sheet there was
no way in hell that probation shouldn't
even been should have been mentioned but
because everyone is doing the new
Progressive thing of releasing every
criminal is expecting it and when they
don't get it they get violent because
you know what the argument is going to
be she was oppressing him it's her fault
she was using her white privilege to put
another black man in the penitentiary
had nothing to do with what he did as a
human being so this is the result of it
now they're going to say I we used to
say unaffected or unaffected well this
is a judge who was doing her job and
they're getting attacked the other
judges who aren't doing their job the
criminals aren't acting like that right
so the message until unfortunately one
of the like it took until the woman the
government worker in Minnesota was
carjacked had blood all of a sudden we
need police we need to get our street
safe it's the same thing now the problem
is it's only happening to judges who are
trying to do their job mhm you know guy
I could see you as a TV
judge anyway that has nothing to do with
this it was a dream I had you know where
were the BFFs that's what I want to know
where's Rusty the bayith remember the
People's Court Rusty he's on his phone
uh oh see I don't think what's his name
Deborah I don't think he really got this
through very care because he's already
lost the motion he's at some point
probably going to be up for parole and
now at the parole hearing his lawyer
will come up and be like oh he served
his debt to society he's a reformed man
and the prosecutor just shows up being
like roll the tape like that guy's never
getting out no he's not and he shouldn't
um that was a wild clip I mean it's
actually impressive he was able to do my
the thing is postco I think we did way
too much like virtual stuff from home I
think we can probably do the next
hearing by Zoom yeah I don't think he
has to be in the courtroom next time he
needs to be in one of those Hannibal
cages ibe he just wanted to give her a
hug for someone finally holding him
[Applause]
accountable ER it's good point you know
Tyra says it's like the expectation was
that he wasn't going to jail absolutely
he has an incredible rap sheet of
felonies domestic violence the guy
clearly he was in he was at that hearing
because he took a baseball back to
somebody and tried to like assault them
with it this is not an IND idual who
should be of his own recognizance ever
allowed into society and he was standing
there right before he leapt to attack
the judge he said I'm not committing any
crimes right now yes and then he and
then she was like well and he was like
oh I'm about to and then decides to like
go after the judge and I I got to tell
you like that was quite the leap and it
it was like he could have probably been
a very good athlete in high school or
college and instead decided to choose a
path of crime he could have used his
athleticism for good instead of evil he
could have maybe gotten a job in that
Star Wars movie you exactly he still can
though hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else